we just saw this story biden basically
defended israel uh
he literally defended israel he says
that there hasn't been a significant
overreaction
as idf bombards gaza and troops mass on
border
yeah biden is paralyzed he doesn't have
he doesn't have the ability to be strong
and firm
it's just not within him he's gonna
stumble and mutter in his words and fall
asleep halfway through
so if anything we could discount any you
know conspiracy theories about
military-industrial complexes or
whatever fine
but it could very well just be that
hamas is like
trump's gone green light yeah because
binding ain't gonna do anything about it
and then israel is like
well we're gonna we're gonna strike back
and what's biden gonna do about it
exactly and at this point israel may be
making the calculation why not go and do
all this the irony in all of this
is that for the left who pretends to
care about the palestinians
trump was the best president for them
because he was able to keep the whole
house in order
because you almost had this like you
know this chaotic energy all the time
that was keeping everybody on their toes
there so if anybody got out of line
he was able to step in and be like well
if you do this it's gonna happen and
they don't know what kind of wild card
he's gonna throw at them look that's the
difference with biden they both know
he's paralyzed exactly look at the
abraham accords
you had these arabic nations signing
these peace treaties and these deals and
these economic ties with israel
and no explosions
but you know what that's why i was
saying that's bad for the
military-industrial complex
that's bad for the establishment that
wants gas pipelines
and then it's really funny because i
think it was i don't know if it was i
don't know if it was jack who pointed
this out but
they shut down the uh gretchen whitmer
in
in michigan wants to shut down this oil
pipeline it's dangerous it's dangerous
the colonial pipeline hack they shut
down keystone we went from being energy
independent to energy dependent
yeah very quickly and it provides
another excuse
to have a presence in the middle east
100 we talked about this just like
couple hours ago we were saying
that essentially you know we need to get
to the point as a nation and this is
part of being anti-war we need to be
energy independent because
if we're not then we need to be worried
about every time an oil field gets
captured by a terror group or gets
burned by a terror group
we were in advice under trump where if
that happened it wasn't such a big
problem for us unless you're investing
in oil you know in the stock market but
for american people at the gas pump it
wasn't a big problem because we were
energy independent enough to deal with
whatever came outside there because we
had enough here
with biden you don't it's it's awfully
convenient for
those who wanted to keep our military in
syria yeah i remember when uh trump
wanted to pull out of syria
and then they basically were like but
the oil so trump says okay fine
we're keeping in just enough troops to
get the oil and he just blurts it out
it was really funny because the anti-war
left is continually like
trump's admitting exactly what the us is
doing yeah and
they don't get it trump was admitting it
on purpose he doesn't want
trump did not want to be there trump
didn't care about it all trump cared
about was america america first energy
independent bring our jobs back make
america great again
he didn't care about being in syria so
when they were like we're not going to
pull our troops out
trump was like why because they're
guarding oil trump said then get
everyone else out and guard the oil and
then he goes on tv and says don't worry
we still have all their oil
and everyone like don't you appreciate
he's pulled the curtain back
he's breaking the fourth wall and
telling you exactly what this is this is
all
theater to distract you from what's
really going on this is what's really
going on so if that's what they want
here they can have that but we're not
gonna do this
remember remember when trump was
standing outside like by the helicopter
or whatever
and he's like we're doing a great
weapons deal with saudi arabia it's
gonna be great for our economy we're
gonna make billions of dollars giving
weapons to this country
and the anti-war left was just like he
he just admitted it all he just came out
and said it
they actually that was the beauty of
trump though you know in so many ways
and and i think that it's something
we're going to see again when he comes
out and do
does these rallies but he was just so
transparent
about all these things and in a weird
way
so much of our country was not ready for
that transparency because
they were conditioned you know through
many different things but you know just
this exposure effect by itself of your
whole life being exposed to people who
lie to you
right having this person just blurt out
the truth all the time
sounds crazy lied about weird stupid
things a lot but like the important
stuff he would just
blurt out the truth and people were so
conditioned to having people in
positions of power lie to them
that that was like just an earthquake
this was how you could tell the agenda
of trump was
was uh was legitimate he would lie about
things
when he would lie about something you
knew was something he actually cared
about domestic policy or
his character and then he would be
openly just like oh yeah we're getting
the oil and we want to pull everybody
else out and
we're selling weapons to these countries
he didn't care about that he didn't want
to keep doing it it meant nothing to him
so he had no problem telling people
because it wasn't part of his agenda
yeah the things he was lying about like
you know stormy daniel stuff or just
like ego stuff
number of people number of people at his
rallies it were things that directly
impacted
his his his mission agenda and stature
in the united states
and it's i there's the intercept said
that he was the simultaneously the most
honest and the most
deceitful president we've ever had
because on these really important issues
he would just like open his mouth and
tell you everything
well the thing that they you know they
never honestly actually talk about is
that he's an entertainer
he's not a politician and when you're an
entertainer you're a storyteller when
you tell stories things are naturally
going to kind of get a little bit
grandiose you know and i think that to
some degree
people need to have common sense and
understand that you know yeah
yeah i will say too when when he had the
inauguration
and he was like there was more people
who watched this than any other group
and the media was like that's a lie that
what they do is these clever tricks
where
trump says we had the biggest
inauguration ever the media then goes
there were only you know 50 000 people
at
in in dc which is which which means
trump lied
and it's like did trump say only in
attendance
or was he referring to all viewership
online in
in general yeah and so they they always
make the assumption in the most
in the worst possible way to make it
look like he's lying or being
manipulative
that was that that's what the media did
the whole time and i guess
that's the story of his presidency
that's right the story of the presidency
now we're now we got joe biden and i
just got to say it's really funny
because i honestly didn't think
we would all be so spot on you know all
of the
like i don't want to say necessarily say
conservative but democrat critical or
establishment critical personalities
be it the disaffected liberals or the
conservatives we're like joe biden's
going to have a radical left policy
agenda it's going to cause more war gas
prices are going to skyrocket the riots
are going to continue
and i mean i genuinely thought that
would happen but i kind of felt like we
wouldn't be
like five for five i thought it would
take six months
that's the thing i didn't know it would
be this fast he's like i mean
he's like on some sort of weird kind of
failure speed i didn't know they made
he's doing speed balls for failure
because he's just like a rocket
and in every other way he's like asleep
i know no no remember that quote from
joe biden i mentioned the other day
where he was like
i can't remember exactly what it was but
he goes the one thing that you gotta
do you know to be great and when when
you're
it's uh anyway
everyone did that yeah he was like
anyway anyway so i'll move on you guys
want me to move on
here i'll tell you what i think's
happening biden comes out and he's all
like you know shaking and confused and
it's you know they're like what's your
plan better calf care
and then all the democrats are just
clapping and cheering for it yeah and
all the conservatives like the dude's
insane he's off his rocker
his brain isn't working and then he goes
i'm gonna get in trouble if i take
questions so i'm gonna
get out of here he walks backstage and
he's like where's jill and then he goes
stands up straight he goes
we're done now moving forward i want
hyperinflation we're gonna decimate this
economy we're gonna drop consumerism
climate change is a very serious problem
now over here i want more more
immigrants coming to the border so
rescind trump's orders
and we're gonna reopen these facilities
we want to create chaos ladies and
gentlemen get the job done and get me
another 50 million of bitcoin
at least you think he's a bumbling fool
but i'll put it this way i'm not saying
this is true
i'm just saying at a certain point the
failures
how could you be in terms of like policy
positions in four months
0 and 5. like the riots are still
happening inflation is getting worse
these are his policy positions they're
dropping the charges on antifa
he's giving out more money for people
not to work he's rescinded trump's
executive orders he's reopened the
migrant facilities
he's funding these palestinian groups
how could that be an
accident it can't be it can't be and by
the way you have to use the correct term
it's not inflation that's happening
happening it's bite inflation bite
inflation is that was that
who came up with that yeah i think so
that was the first thing
but it is it's bite inflation it's
stagflation yeah it's people not working
and inflation at the same time which is
like the worst most dangerous thing
possible
i just i can't believe it's an accident
it's not when i saw the story from the
guardian where it was like gretchen
whitmer orders the closure of an oil
pipeline in michigan i was like
get out of here there's no way it was a
coincidence
that we have a pipeline shut down the
keystone's shut down and people are
running and filling up garbage bags with
gas
and then she's like now's a good time to
shut down another pipeline yep
that's you're really honest you're spot
on and this is not the first time that
any of this has happened
this is the playbook to color
revolutions to bringing marxism into a
country
you need to make it as weak as possible
in so many different areas
that all you have to do is kick one leg
of that desk out
and it's all gonna topple because every
single one of them has been loosened
frogs frogs in a pot you if you so we
talked about this before
shocking the system i've been saying we
should abolish the police for the for
the past couple of months why
most of the good cops have left we've
got tremendous reports uh
michael tracy report on this huge
numbers of people arrested for not
wearing masks or for running small
businesses
you had a woman in south of minneapolis
arrested because she opened her coffee
bar during coven
so you have cops arresting these people
meanwhile antifa's getting cut loose i
get it the cops still arrest them but
they get cut loose
now most of the good cops have quit and
what's left are the cops will do
whatever they're told
if you leave this system as it is we can
already see what's happening
black lives matter calls the police they
they're they're at a guy's house he
brandishes a shotgun in his own home
they call the cops the cops arrest him
from his own home
they don't want to abolish the police
they've weakened the police department
demoralizing to the point
where they can get cops who will come in
and enforce anything they're told
conservatives now need to be need to be
paying attention to this
because they're frogs in a pot boiling
defending the police
and that changes are slow enough to
where within a year
you're going to have your woke police
force they're going to arrest you in
your own home they're already doing it
in which case you can be a frog in a pot
or you can be a frog someone threw a
rock at
get shocked out of it you got to think
about it i would say this this would be
my pushback to it is that
i think that the country is so divided
that
in the cities that are controlled by
democrats the police forces the police
chiefs have been chosen by the democrat
mayors
the police forces have been neutered
essentially and you're right that most
of the good people have left and so what
we have left there
in those cities is police departments
that essentially bow down to the mob
but in the rest of america we we don't
like in most parts there's some places
where we've seen them act crazy over
covet orders and stuff like that but i
can say in tennessee
like our local police they refuse to
enforce any of the mandates they refuse
to enforce anything like that
and so that's a very different world and
none of those officers are doing their
jobs
let's clarify i'll clarify when the left
says abolish the police they're not
talking about tennessee they're talking
about new york city yeah
and i'm like yeah go for it i just want
to clarify that from my home state
um so you know i think that that idea
that it's all
one thing is something we have to be
very clear about but in terms of what's
happening in the big cities you know
honestly i don't know exactly
what the answer is because let them get
rid of their cops when you look at it
you know if that's what all of them want
they're gonna have to see what the
outcomes are and honestly i think the
real answer is is for the police who
are there right now and are putting
themselves in harm way in harm's way
when
they bow down to these people they need
to walk away from their job
ultimately my point was if we keep
sitting here as the police departments
are attacked and demoralized and good
cops quit and bad cops
take jobs we are frogs in a pot being
boiled
and you won't realize when the change
has happened when all of a sudden your
cop knocks on your door and says
you know where's your critical race
theory book prove you have it
you'll just be like how did we get to
this point because if at any point if
the democrats came out right now and
said we're going to mandate that all
police arrest anybody who explains who
displays white privilege people would
revolt it would be
people would freak out they'd be
screaming they'd be like demanding
people get fired
you'd do it slowly over the course of a
year two years or three years
and then people are just like did you
hear about john you got something about
white privilege i don't know what
happened and then one by one these
things keep happening and then
eventually it's normal
it's incrementalism if you do it so i'll
i'll use the story of ebay which i've
told before
when ebay first started the website was
yellow do you ever hear the story no the
website was yellow
one day they decided we want to redesign
the website they made it they made the
website white
they got inundated with complaints
people were like i hate it it's awful
so they changed it back every day they
incremented it one shade closer to white
over the course of a year a year later
the website was white and no one
complained
because it was so gradual no one noticed
so
right now what's happening is you
mentioned like marxism
and coming in and weakening the country
if they came in and stood up and said
we you know i'm a marxist candidate who
wants to run for office
they'd never win nope you get in the
democratic party now they've gone to the
point where they've actually entertained
socialism and it's working yep
now they can tell you socialism is a
good thing socialism is great and now
people are starting to actually they i
remember like two or three years ago
they added the word socialism to the
democratic party wikipedia page
yep tenets socialism they're doing it
slow enough because you can't
just do it all at once for a few reasons
people notice right away a massive
change and don't like it
but they need to make it uh transition
along with the aging demographics
yeah so when we have these leftists on
the show and they're in their 20s
and they're like you gotta vote for joe
biden and then i mention the obama
administration they go oh i was 15 when
it happened i have no idea yeah i'm like
oh so when they're blowing up kids
you weren't paying you'll learn this
time you'll learn this time but it's not
just about
the individual it's about the
demographics so you're spot on because
like
fidel castro if you ask somebody is
fidel castro was he a communist you'd be
like oh yeah absolutely well he never
admitted he was
in the lead-up to the revolution he only
admitted he was a marxist
after they'd consolidated enough power
he had already taken power
and they had an alliance with the soviet
union that's when he said
i'm a marxist before that he said i'm a
humanist i'm a catholic yeah yeah
he showed us that image where it was
like a humanist revolution yeah and then
we know what happened after that yep
you look at what happens and uh i'm
sorry i i i can shout this out whenever
i get the opportunity
maduro giving a speech to a starving
nation in venezuela
and then just reaching into a drawer
pulling an empanada and taking a big old
bite you know what i'm gonna do
that is that is that is them
encapsulated
can we sell that as an nft you know like
that's that's the marxism we were
talking about i can't believe he did
that
i know it's insane they're so brazen
they know that once they've demoralized
you to that point
he can eat food in front of you as you
starve and no one will do anything about
it yep
step one is get on tv and treat
americans like dogs and tell them that
uh
you know they they can get a prize hold
on dogs are traded pretty well in this
country no
okay maybe like but i'm talking about
the training aspect the training aspect
saying cut you can have your treat
if you take your medicine that like we
saw today yeah what was that what was it
was that thing from biting i don't even
pulled up you know he's like if you get
your vaccine you otherwise you wear a
mask that's the deal and i'm like no
no it isn't joe like i don't live
wherever it is you live okay because
even though he said that
dc's operating under different rules so
the cdc comes out
and they're like if you're vaccinated
you don't have to wear a mask
well washington dc doesn't care they
said that washington dc is a federal
jurisdiction but they're doing whatever
they want
texas hasn't cared for some time yeah
they've got no mass man in florida the
same
and out here they've already announced
the end of the mass mandates in several
states and some of them are blue states
and i'm like i don't know who he's
talking to
who's who's joe biden talking to new
york city i guess he's talking to
himself through the guise of his abusive
father
in the 50s when that's how they talk the
meaner and the more cruel you were the
more likely the kid was to be
subservient and say yes sir
i don't know man i i look at how kids
are getting raised today and it's like
i i i feel like kids today are the
example of the the epitome of
shut up mom kind of kids well the
disrespect today is crazy we got to get
that under control in america especially
dads need to like
be a dad don't let them don't let them
talk to their mom
disrespectfully and say teach them how
to treat people because how they treat
people at home that's going to be
reflection how they treat people on the
outside and you don't need to be this
brutal dictator of a parent
to instill respect lead by example and
the first time they step out of line
take away everything that they
they like playing with and doing and
that that'll effectively work most of
the time for me
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you